did no one else do that yeah because
they're [ __ ] idiots they can read the
instructions
[Music]
hatchimals
no i'm thinking tamagotchi brought to
life i remember last year the hatchimals
were completely sold out everywhere out
of curiosity i did check amazon like
instead of a price it was just like
nope hey oh my baby the age range is
five years and up i fall into that
category
the fun it has started how do you hatch
this bad boy hold and rub the bottom of
the egg to hear my heart beat do i rub
it vigorously or like lovingly both of
those words are weird i don't think real
egg birth things make noises when
they're still inside the egg taking a
little creative license with that i just
keep doing this when does it start to
poke its head through this is how you
teach kids patience though to be honest
oh you know it's it's it's a little
sexual i'm not gonna lie but
it's also a baby so let's just clear our
minds you thought it not me how long
does this take this is outrageous it
must be like a heat technology can i
just get a blow dryer i feel like i'm
trying to start a fire like in my cave
man this is why you always oh
oh my god this is the coolest toy in the
world oh my god this is like jurassic
park
it's going pretty hard i'm having fun
now that's right yo right now it's
pretty ugly though i'm really impressed
with the technology behind this toy
though that it can rotate within this
little package and poke its little beak
out
i'm gonna use it as a nutcracker maybe
once it's alive put it to work go oh
it's done all right i'm popping off the
hood
that's pretty cute just gonna help it
out a little bit
he's glittery he's a little glittery
sweetie okay the legs are straight up
transformers right here does it make a
great toy in a toy store universe but
like the evil one that sid has where
it's like all [ __ ] up as like an eye
patch and it's like guts are spilling
out if i was a kid and i didn't know how
much it cost i'd love it so mine's
broken does not appear to want to be a
part of society i feel like breathed
fire evolved you take off one of his
wings and attach like a
claw saw hand that would be pretty neat
ew
stop
it it has glowing eyes i don't like that
brown's gonna be not a fan of that i
could go without that you're gonna scare
the devil out of him you know look man
i'm trying to enjoy a delicious language
burrito yeah lunch i chose
he's a gravy
he's a shania we got ourselves a shady